it was time to kick off the pro bowl
today the first official news conference
was held at wetlands park near sam boyd
stadium we'll explain why it was there
in a moment
it was a wee bit cold outside this
morning the party kicked off with
mascots like the ravens po
we found out his middle name it's alan
the first name would be
can't even help me with this from the
first name anybody
maybe edgar okay the seahawks the
seahawks love that pro bowl trophy right
there shining in the sun the heroes were
the cheerleaders showing up in their
warm weather clothes that had to be cold
for them they held the event at the
wetlands park because verizon and the
nfl are footing the bill to plant a
bunch of trees at the park
this event is incredible and we're proud
to be a part of it we're proud to have
people from the nfl people from other
teams other communities come and see
what's so special about this community
and this is a great way to showcase it
right to have our commitment to
restoring
the natural beauty of the environment
and making sure that we're part of the
solution here with the local environment
and the local community
i was hoping for a nice fire out there
to keep us warm
not a big fire at the wetlands park like
they had just a small one but anyway
after the news conference the kids got
together planted some trees
they don't plant themselves they did the
heavy lifting the school kids did 1200
trees will be planted at the wetlands
park in case you did not know it's
important ecologically to our valley
because lake mead with the vegetation
there the water filters through the
valley down to lake mead
and dumps into the lake